a big part of the death of any hero is
their final words
sometimes those last words are packed
with meaning other times a hero's last
words are cut off by a sudden
and unexpected demise either way here
are the last words of
every fallen star wars hero from the
original trilogy
you may not recognize him by his name
but every star wars fan remembers reymus
antilles
he's the very first person that darth
vader kills on screen in star wars a new
hope
in imperial star destroyer captures a
rebel ship looking for the plans to the
death star that the rebels stole
vader boards the ship and finds the
first rebel leader he can
who just happens to be antilles vader
interrogates him
and things quickly turn violent after
vader lifts antilles off the ground by
his throat
vader is furious and demands to know
where the stolen death star plans are
but antilles plays dumb
as he gasps for air until
[Music]
he tries to convince vader that the sith
lord has it all wrong
that the ship has no connection to the
rebels and is traveling on
ordinary diplomatic business but vader
chokes him harder
and asks if this is a counselorship
where is the ambassador great question
vader
unfortunately antilles never has a
chance to respond
he gives his life without telling vader
where the plans were
at the time of course they were in the
hands of princess leia
the death of bru lars is extremely sad
she's the first civilian victim
seen in star wars and her ruthless
murder demonstrates how
evil the empire truly is peru is the
adoptive mother of luke skywalker
after luke's biological mother padme
died giving birth to luke
obi-wan kenobi hid the child obi-wan
took luke to tatooine to be raised by
brew and owen lars
who work as moisture farmers not too far
away obi-wan settles into a little home
and watches luke grow up
carefully protecting him the larzas are
good folks
they stay out of trouble and want
nothing to do with the empire
or the rebel alliance but that doesn't
stop the empire from showing up
their home and killing them at the
beginning of a new hope
storm troopers are looking for the droid
c3po and r2d2
and track them to peru's house at the
time luke isn't home
the last time we see brew alive she's
talking to her husband about luke's
chores
owen asks her if luke took the droids
with him and she responds
i think so luke later returns home to
find owen and bruce charred bodies
it's at that moment that luke resolves
to fight
the empire to become a jedi and to join
obi-wan on his quest
it is essentially the turning point that
sets off
luke's character arc in the same scene
where we hear beru's last words
owen lars speaks his final words as well
owen is anakin skywalker's stepbrother
one day obi-wan kenobi showed up at
owen's door and asked him to raise luke
as an adoptive father
honestly owen and brew are heroes in
their own right for doing that
tragically the empire kills both of them
owen's last words on screen are a
conversation with his wife beru about
luke's responsibilities
previously luke left home with the two
droids they just bought
referring to luke owen says well you
better have those units in the south
range repaired by midday or they'll be
held at pay
owen may have been a loving foster
father but that doesn't mean he wasn't
serious about pushing luke to do his
chores
it's unfortunate that his final words
were somewhat bitter toward luke
shortly after owen was killed by
stormtroopers looking for the two droids
that lars recently purchased
owen's death prompts luke to leave
tatooine become a jedi and fight the
empire
of all the quotes on this list this one
might be the most
famous obi-wan kenobi and his group of
friends are trying to escape the death
star
during the process kenobi crosses paths
with darth vader and the two have
one last lightsaber duel it's an
extremely
tense moment because these two
characters have a ton of history
together
kenobi trained anakin aka darth vader to
become a jedi but anakin then betrayed
kenobi
and the jedi it probably didn't help
that during a previous lightsaber duel
kenobi chopped off three of vader's
limbs and left him in a volcano to catch
fire which
is the reason vader now wears his black
suit anyhow
during the duel kenobi warns vader if
you strike me down
i shall become more powerful than you
can possibly imagine
while fighting vader kenobi locks eyes
with luke skywalker in the distance
right then kenobi lowers his guard and
allows darth vader to kill him
strangely enough kenobi's body
disappears after he dies
later on we learn that kenobi can visit
people from the afterlife as a force
ghost
obviously kenobi continues talking after
this line
but it's still the last thing he says
before he dies
and becomes one with the force in a new
hope
the climax of the movie takes place in
space outside the death star
the empire has learned that the secret
base for the rebel alliance is on yavin
4
so they fly the death star there to blow
up the rebels
once and for all when the rebels learn
about this they send a fleet of fighters
to destroy it
having recently learned about a small
but deadly weakness in the death star
it's an epic battle but as you can
imagine there are many casualties
the first death for the rebels is jack
porkins aka
red6 we'll just ignore the fact that
george lucas named an overweight
character
porkins one of the rebel leaders orders
the destruction of a turret that is
giving the rebels a lot of problems
perkins is on it but after taking out
the cannon porken's ship
hits debris which damages his x-wing and
forces him to fly through crossfire
a fellow fighter named big starklighter
insists that perkins get out of that
dangerous area but perkins is stubborn
over the radio he tells biggs
his words are cut off because in that
moment his ship
is shot down by lasers we're still at
the battle of yevin the one in the new
hope outside the death star
our next fallen hero is john d brennan
better known by his callsign
red four once the rebel fighters fly
close to the death star the empire
unleashes its fire power but quickly
realizes that it's impossible to shoot
down
all the rebels as one imperial officer
points out the rebel ships are just too
close to their turrets
so darth vader instructs his underlings
to man their own
short-range attack ships called tie
fighters and take out the rebel fighters
one at a time the first wave of tie
fighters finds a victim all too soon
john brennan the rebel fighters can
communicate with one another by radio
and one of them notices that the turrets
have mysteriously stopped shooting
the reason is soon discovered as the tie
fighters start blasting brandon's ship
his final words over the radio before
blowing up our quote
i'm hit tyree is another rebel alliance
pilot who dies during the battle of
yavin in a new hope
we rarely remember the names of these
fighters because they're only on screen
for a short time
and they refer to one another by their
fighter designations in this case
tyree's designation is gold 2 and he
flies a y-wing bomber
while attacking the death star the
rebels are attacked by tie fighters but
they eliminate that first wave
pretty quickly it probably helped that
luke skywalker was kicking some tail
alongside them
seemingly everything is clear for the
rebels to start their attack run so
gold squadron begins their descent and
starts flying through the trench of the
death star
huge laser cannons start shooting at
them but then mysteriously cease fire
that's when tyree says the guns they've
stopped
well surprise surprise there's another
batch of tie fighters and
this time darth vader himself is leading
the pack
vader blasts the first rebel craft in
his sights which just happens to be
tyrese
[Music]
not long after tyree dies john vander
also perishes
vander goes by his nickname dutch and
during the battle of yavin he is also
known as gold leader
tyree and vander are flying through the
death star's trench closing in on the
small ventilation shaft which they must
bull's-eye with proton torpedoes in
order to destroy the space station
behind them a trio of tie fighters
appears one of which is a unique tie
advanced piloted by darth vader after
vader blasts tyree he begins shooting at
vander
in those few seconds vander argues with
davis crail over the radio
davish insists that they continue their
attack run repeating the line
stay on target but vander wants to pull
up because they're in danger of dying by
enemy
fire vander keeps trying to persuade
davish even to his last words
loosen up it's not clear vander is
telling his fellow rebel fighter that
they need to abort the attack or simply
relax their position
but we'll never get an answer because
right after that vader shoots jon vander
into pieces
it looks like vander was right they
should have pulled out of the trench
dealt with the tie fighters first and
then resumed their attack run
soon after jon vander dies in battle
davish pop's krill
also falls again crail aka gold 5 is the
pilot who keeps saying stay on target
while gold squadron is trying to take
out the death star crail is aware of the
tie fighters that are on his tail
because he just watched his two friends
get destroyed
by enemy fire crail is still flying
through the trench at this point but
he's alone and darth vader is following
close behind in his tie fighter
crail isn't sure what to do so he
reports to the rest of the rebels
gold five to red leader lost tyrion
then crail says his very last words over
the radio
referring to the enemy tie fighters he
says that came from
behind maybe crail was going to ask the
others to take out the enemy fighters
before they could shoot him down but
unfortunately crail dies right then and
there vader
who's now 3-0 shoots down yet another
rebel fighter
we tend to remember vader killing people
with his lightsaber or a force choke
but he also kills quite a few
individuals from the cockpit of his
personal tie fighter
and one of the victims of vader's tie is
therinet
who goes by red10 at this point during
the battle of yavin the enemy tie
fighters seem to have disappeared
the rebel fighters decide that this is
their chance to enter the trench and
attempt to destroy the death star
garvin dries red leader is super focused
on getting to that target
his face glued to the monitor he says
almost
there meanwhile his fellow rebels are
trying to cover him
right then vader shows up and his tie
advanced net tries to hold them off but
he only buys his friend a few seconds
before vader shoots him down
net's last words are i can't hold them
garvin dries better known as red leader
was almost the hero of a new hope
dress is the rebel fighter who fires at
the death star's small but vulnerable
exhaust port
nearly hitting his mark unfortunately
the torpedoes don't go in
and only impacts the surface of the
death star which is pretty disappointing
for the rebels
dries pulls up out of the trench only to
learn that his starboard engine is
cooked
he's a little nervous especially because
he doesn't know where those blasted tie
fighters went
but the mission must go on realizing
that his ship is in
no condition to take out the death star
dries tells the others
get that up for your attack run he's
essentially passing on the
responsibility to the others
maybe dries was going to try to provide
cover fire while his friends descended
into the death star trench
but we'll never know right after that
darth vader shoots dries x-wing causing
it to crash into the surface of the
death star
and that's the end of red leader
with so many casualties and time running
out the rebel fighters decide it's time
for another run at destroying the death
star
a group of rebel x-wing fighters
descends into the trench with luke
leading the way it's a tense moment luke
is telling r2d2 to fix his ship while
dodging turret fire
the death star is almost in position to
destroy the rebel base
and one fighter named big's dark lighter
is covering for luke
darklighter or red 3 is tasked with
protecting his childhood friend luke
from the tie fighters
his goal is to give luke enough time to
destroy the death star but the tie
fighters are right on his tail
darklighter begs luke to hurry up saying
over the radio hurry up luke
wait wait he probably knows right then
that his time is up darth vader cool and
calm as ever
shoots dark lighter down his ship
explodes against the side of the death
star trench
dak ralter is the first hero to die in
the empire strikes back
dak was a close friend of luke skywalker
and a fellow fighter for the rebel
alliance
luke had to watch many of his close
friends die in the fight against the
empire and dak
was yet another one at the beginning of
the empire strikes back
darth vader is hunting for the secret
location of the new rebel base
after a galaxy-wide search vader finds
it hidden on the planet hoth
and begins an assault on the frozen
world dak
and luke among other fighters must
defend the base to buy time for the
others to escape and relocate to a new
planet
the two operate the same snow speeder
with lucas the pilot and dax seated
behind him as the gunner
while flying around during the massive
battle dak tries to fix the damaged snow
speeder saying
i'll have to cut in the auxiliary
moments later dak
is shot to death the worst part is that
luke has to keep flying
around with dak dead behind him after
crash landing
luke barely escapes the snow speeder as
a gigantic
atat steps on it crushing dax body
inside
the ever wise yoda lived to the ripe old
age of
900 he trained tons of jedi knights
imparted wisdom as a member of the jedi
council
and personally mentored luke skywalker
he's a bit kooky
and talks funny but that just makes us
love him all the more
and don't let his age or size deceive
you
the dude can force lift an x-wing out of
a swamp
and go berserk with a lightsaber as he
proved an attack of the clones when he
faced count dooku
but even legendary jedi masters can die
of old age
in return of the jedi luke visits yoda
seeking counsel
but yoda is ready to pass away due to
old age so he lies down on his bed
in his dying words yoda says luke
there is another skywalker yoda is
referring to leia organa
who luke does not yet realize is his
twin sister
she may also bring hope to the galaxy if
luke should fail
then yoda dies disappearing and becoming
a force ghost we have arrived at the
battle of endor
which is the climax of return of the
jedi and the entire original trilogy
han solo is trying to disable a shield
generator on the forest moon of
endor meanwhile in orbit the rebel
alliance is assaulting the second
death star in the famous words of
admiral akbar
it's a trap the empire anticipated the
rebel attack and prepared an ambush
which ends up killing
a lot of rebels among them is gris
fricks
while the rebel army waits for the death
star shield to be disabled they decide
to do something
crazy attack the massive fleet of star
destroyers that's nearby
their logic as explained by lando
calrissian is
will last longer against those star
destroyers than we will against that
death star
and we might just take a few of them
with us frix shoots up star destroyer
and realizes that it's about to explode
moments before being caught in the blast
he warns his fellow fighters
it's no surprise that these would be the
last words of a fallen star wars hero
after all star wars is about well wars
in the stars
immediately after an explosion kills
grizz spricks another rebel pilot named
eckerlach young
perishes in the fight it's unclear if
the same explosion that took out fricks
also hit yong's ship
or if young was simply hit by enemy fire
we don't see
exactly what causes his demise and
that's
natural for a massive chaotic fight like
the battle of endor
the scene cuts to yong in his cockpit
and he yells i'm hit
if you're a star wars fan you may not
recognize these final words
right away but you'll remember them soon
enough because of the scene that
immediately follows
during this point in the battle of
vendor several rebel fighters are inside
the death star while admiral akbar's
fleet remains outside
holding off the empire's star destroyers
akbar decides that they need to do
something to buy more time for the
fighters so he tells
all his forces to concentrate their fire
on the biggest enemy ship
darth vader's superstar destroyer
executor
soon after the superstar destroyer loses
its deflector shield
and that's when admiral piet panics and
orders the ship's forward batteries to
increase their rate of fire
well something does get through are vel
crined
krenid's a-wing gets clipped by enemy
fire and he loses control of his ship
his ship flies right into piet's face
ending both of their lives
his last word ah unable to save himself
krinid makes the best of the situation
and aims his a-wing
straight into the bridge of the
superstar destroyer exploding on impact
and taking out the massive battleship
along with him
the executor then crashes into the death
star which is a
huge victory for the rebels but alas
they lost arvel krennic in the process
don't even tell us you didn't cry when
you saw this scene
this was the moment the entire star wars
fan base
hoped for during the original trilogy
the death of darth vader
and the lingering question of whether or
not he would convert
back to the light side after darth vader
repents and throws the emperor down a
shaft
he tries to escape with his son luke but
vader now redeemed as anakin skywalker
has sustained heavy injuries and can't
go on
it's a deep moment a father who is proud
of his son
and a son who doesn't want to see his
newly redeemed father die
anakin asks luke to remove his mask so
they can see each other as they really
are
his last words to his son are tell your
sister
you were right no one including leia
believed that luke could turn his father
back from the dark side
even the mighty darth vader was wrong
about himself
there was good inside of him all along
for his last minute conversion
we list anakin skywalker as a hero check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus
even more looper videos about star wars
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]